A yeah and Kaolin Kaolin
oh alive.
I've been listening to radio lab on the way over here and they have a new
episode out about the asteroid impact that killed the dinosaurs.
Yeah.
Holy Shit Man.
Right.
Apparently they tell me if I'm right about this before you tell me more.
So I want to see if I have a little knowledge right.
There is an under,
like there's a very hard layer of rock that covers a large part of the earth.
Right.
And that is proof that somehow there was an asteroid that hit and it got really,
really hot and the rock got dad is a morons version of a size that they clearly
laid out by the way.
So worse than I'm also like there's a rock that got melted under the ground.
Undeniable evidence of the rock of from this space.
Every so layer of the earth,
the crust of the earth is super hard because it got really hot after an asteroid
hit,
everybody died.
Then they found dinosaur bones in it.
Yeah Bro.
They don't believe in dinosaurs cause I'm,
you know,
I have something called the Bible at home,
but some people don't believe in dinosaurs.
Do you know that this flat earth folks,
dinosaurs or fake,
why is it that most flat earthers from my experience are generally super good at
like a discipline that has nothing to do with astrophysics,
like Jujitsu,
like they spent a lot of time on a mat,
but then they have really strong political opinions about why central banks.
It's think it's just a lack of real education and then you get caught up in
these youtube things that show you a secret and it's very attractive.
It's very attractive to look,
find out about some hidden stuff like,
oh my God,
I can't believe they did this to hid from us.
The fact that the earth is flat.
Jesus Christ spaces fake too,
bro.
Space is baked.
Satellites aren't real or low flying planes,
their planes.
There's constantly beaming down these information from the sky.
Satellites are not real nuclear bombs and not real.
Yeah,
not really just big bombs.
But then the problem is when you break your leg and you have to set your bone or
you get staff and you have to trust big Pharma to cure it,
or you use your,
your iPhone and it works and you're talking to somebody and that's a big one.
But why?
Why is that technology something you trust?
Your fucking iPhone has a global positioning.
Satellite chip in it stopped horse it,
it links up with the fucking one that's in the sky and it tells you where you
are on the map.
That's why your Google maps works.
Jesus fucking probably only five or six flat earthers no,
there's a lot.
There's thousands of them.
Well,
okay,
but that really means only five or six.
I think the problem with all of them is that they just got
married to the idea and then they're fighting it and if you fight it with
someone who doesn't know what they're talking about,
not that I do know what I'm talking about,
but if you fight it with like a Sean Carroll or like a real,
a real scientific study,
they,
there's so much evidence that the earth is round and no evidence that the earth
is flat.
It's one of those things where it's just like,
what are you guys doing?
You're chasing your tail.
This is crazy.
Too busy holiday or youtube.
I'm too busy for bigfoot ideas.
Yeah,
that's definitely,
and that might have been a real thing.
It was a real animal.
Yeah.
There was a real creature called Jack Handle Piss.
I guess it was a real animal.
It was like eight foot tall by Peto Hominid.
It absolutely exists.
Probably.
Yeah,
like a giant,
giant gorilla didn't exist.
Imagine seeing a gorilla,
right?
Like Jesus Christ.
What the fuck is that thing?
Six foot 600 pounds.
Jean Hsu,
huge Harry Black beast with a giant Chaston,
enormous arms and towns on his chest runs on all fours and you're like fucking
fangs when they fly through the air,
each other lashed crazy,
smash into each other and fight.
Holy Fuck Man.
If you didn't know that was real,
I know.
And you ran into a gorilla,
you'd be like,
and by the way,
they didn't know mountain gorillas were even a thing until the early 19 hundreds
their religion.
Yeah.
When was the discovery of mountain gorillas don't make the most giant chimps in
the Congo or are hybrid?
No,
they don't anymore because they have DNA.
The,
they're the only chimpanzee species or subspecies.
Cause she'd say they found the hazard crest on its skull like a gorilla.
1902 bro.
Damn.
Yeah.
A German explore at a captain Robert Vaughn.
Better hinge,
the mountain gorilla was named the Gorilla Burin g in honor of the captain and
fuck,
look,
I mean,
imagine that thing.
How about those?
That guy who was an anti poaching a agent,
he helps protect gorillas from poachers and he got them to pose standing up in a
selfie.
And even better,
there's video of him tickling the gorillas and the grills laughing,
laughing like a person in,
it's crazy.
So was there a a big foot?
Fuck yeah,
there was a big foot.
Yeah.
It was a real thing.
That's why there's so many stories about it.
It probably died off 100,000 years ago or something.
Right.
You know,
every meet or that just,
they're just vet,
not gorillas.
Gorillas are,
we are closer to chimpanzees than chimpanzees and gorillas.
Is that true?
Yeah.
Wow.
Well,
the,
I think it's interesting in Goma where those groups of mail chimps expand their
territory,
they kill other males and then just moved their women and children into the area
that they annex.
Yeah.
Isn't that crazy ambitious?
They just,
as groups fall,
dat fall on the smaller tribes of,
of chimps and decimate them.
There's so many,
so many similarities to humans.
So many,
yeah.
But these,
um,
Bondo apes,
they call them.
This is the,
um,
the giant champ.
There's these,
they nest on the ground to like gorillas.
Are they as violent as they live in large communities like chimps,
the little blue,
the locals have two names for chimps over there.
They have one that they called tree beaters does the regular science chimps and
the other ones that called lion killers.
They're so big.
They've,
they've,
they've got videos of these things eating a leopard.
What?
Yeah,
they don't know if it,
yeah,
they're enormous champs.
So they don't know if it killed the leopard or if the leopard died and then
they're eating it.
They don't know.
But they do.
No one was eating a fucking leopard.
So you kind of think yummy kitty cat when they're standing up.
They're taller than me.
I'm five,
eight there,
six feet tall.
You're six feet tall.
So the your height,
your height,
but it chimp and a Jack Champ,
God was probably 200 5,300 pounds.
Well,
they say they're 400 pounds.
There wasn't that.
They have something I don't believe Kansas City Zoo.
No,
I don't believe they do.
I think they do know they have two giant chimps.
If you let it as big chips.
Those are just big champs.
They're huge.
They've had chimps that are over 200 pounds to vet some enormous chance,
but they've never had one of these.
Did they live in a very specific area of the Congo,
but they've seen them.
Yes.
They have video of them.
They have photographs of him.
You can see videos and UC camera trap photos.
There are real animal.
It's a big animal man.
So really big chimp.
That's amazing to imagine to see of the six foot chimp.
No,
no.
I didn't know they eat your face and your genitals.
No thanks.
Just imagine standing there.
You turn a corner and is a chimp as tall as you looking at you disaster.
Yeah.
I have to go low.
If you ever see,
you know.
No,
it doesn't matter what.
There was a traveling circus where they had a chimp and they would muscle it and
they'd have any man.
The biggest man that just to hold the chimp down for six seconds.
If you could tell our three seconds and no man has ever going to do it.
They just horse.
There's just 150 pound champ and you wouldn't even,
even if it was muzzled man,
it gets still rip your arms off.
Like what are you doing?
Yeah.
You may not have Jello.
Have you ever held it?
I've held a small one,
a baby one playing with my puppy and it was his back felt like would like
perfectly this is,
that's exactly [inaudible] Henderson problems.
Yes,
exactly.
Like that hasn't been he's,
he's gotta be part chimp.
Yeah.
But I had a two one two year old,
one once a on a fear,
not fear factor and use radio.
And when we're on the set,
the scene actually got cut out.
We never wound up using the scene,
but there was a guy who was like an animal trainer and he had a couple of
different animals with them and one was a baby chimp in diapers and this baby
chimp got on my back.
I'm beat beat on my back a couple of times and I'm was like,
what stuff?
Fuck.
It was like you hitting me.
I was like,
wow,
that's fucking little tiny thing.
Just wailed on me.
She,
they're so strong,
they're a little bodies,
just hard corded,
no neck take crazy punishing.
But um,
that thing in the Congo Mans,
it's apparently in a very difficult spot to reach.
It's very dangerous to go through there.
When Justin wren goes through there,
he has something hair raising stories about being held up at gunpoint.
You know,
people thought they were gonna they were gonna kill somebody.
And Yeah,
a lot of the people,
a lot of the,
apparently a lot of the sort of uh,
soldiers and people are committed atrocities from the,
the uh,
war in Rwanda.
What kind of waiting their bands kind of moved into the Congo and in,
you know,
in the jungle,
who knows who doesn't is a lot of crime.
Justin wren is a saint.
Yeah.
Cause he's eight wells.
He's a legitimate saint.
Yeah.
Really is.
He's gotten malaria three times visiting the Congo and building wells.
Unbelievable.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
He told us some amazing stories.
Heartbreaking.
It's amazing.
The cash APP,
which is one of my sponsors also sponsors fight for the forgotten to give people
the $5 every time someone signs up and uses the code.
Joe Rogan and they've built a their building wells right now because of that.
Who was the latest number?
I forget what the number was.
They sent me an updated,
like very early on there were,
they had built two wells and then they built a bunch more and provided water to
a shit ton of people down there.
I don't know the exact statistic guy who wrote moonwalking with Einstein.
Uh,
the houses he,
it's a book about memory and stuff.
Really Smart Guy.
He lived at the pygmies in the Congo for a long time.
Ah,
that's what Justin wren is doing.
It's all that and said that they smoke copious amounts of wheat.
At least one of the tribes they live with.
Is that the boat?
Yeah.
Joshua.
For for what a name?
Yeah,
we are four
and I never seen what is it,
you know,
these are people that truly have been almost untouched by Western civilization
and he's like,
well no.
I mean they die of stupid things.
Like you know,
you got an infection and you just,
you know,
you don't have antibiotics was a lot of bacteria and parasites and stuff to get
stomach parasites from water,
skin diseases and weird things like that.
Yeah,
the jungles,
not even if you have evolved to live in it.
It's not a very,
I spent enough time in the Indonesian rainforest.
I've never seen the bugs like that in my life.
I've never seen anything like it.
It's so loud.
It sounds like it takes the loudest street in Manhattan and I'm not kidding.
That's how loud the insects and birds and everything are,
and then you'd have to carry the bug.
Spray does not work.
Never tell you this bug spray.
You've got to carry a sulfur coil.
Good luck with the mosquitoes.
Bugs,
right.
They laugh at your fucking,
at your bug spray.
You got to carry it.
You have to burn a sulfur coil and you just carry it.
Hold it.
That's correct.
And
when you wake up and they just,
they're all over the place.
We were doing this,
I god,
I was 21.
Did they,
did they have thermo cells back then?
I don't think so.
Yeah.
Thermo sells a shit.
Do you ever use the thermostat?
Oh my God.
They're fucking game changer.
Really?
Yeah.
It's um,
it's a device that has like a heating coil in it and some fuel and you ignite it
and the,
the heating coil,
it heats up and you put this little pad across the screen and this little pad
has this stuff in it.
The mosquitoes hate.
It's probably terrible for you.
Some fun chemical,
but the chemical wafs up in the air and I'm telling you,
it creates like a 10 foot bubble around.
You were no mosquitoes.
Yeah.
And eat,
look,
even if it's a little bad for you,
maybe it's like smoking a pack of cigarettes.
Yeah.
That doesn't get fed on.
I'm not using it every day.
I wouldn't recommend using it every day.
But if it's different between like enjoy,
like if you're in a place like Alaska.
Exactly.
What about Edmonton up there?
Yeah.
You get same thing came back with like,
no,
fuck you up.
Those mosquitoes man.
Yeah,
they,
they're so aggressive because they're only alive for like three months,
you know,
so cold up there.
Nature could give a fuck about you.
I love people that are into nature and like,
listen man,
they don't even know what nature is.
Try to go try to raise crops in South Africa when animals,
when elephants were all everywhere and lions and leopards are now,
even now,
these poor villagers that they,
they're poor and they build these crops and they have this farm and they have
all this food for their village and then elephant's Roman 20 officers go,
hey man,
and that's a wrap.
Yeah,
you're not going to go
stomp on me.
I mean,
and then people get mad when people shoot the elephants.
It's like,
okay,
I get it,
but I don't know what you want here.
Like they have a lot of stories about elephants have this mistake in South
Africa.
There was this guy who was a farmer and he had a donkey and it was tied up and
the elephants came into his property and he shot guns and got him the hell away
from there.
And then the next day the elephants came back and stomped his fucking donkey
into mush.
Whoa.
Just stomped and the donkey was on a rope and they were like really gang gang,
gang.
And then of course the other neighboring farm and the elephants came,
she,
she laid out a bunch of food for them in the eye and they spared her her crops.
There are all these elephants have this mystique,
which is all,
by the way,
maybe the biggest day holds in the world.
They hate everybody,
but there was so nice.
I was in Thailand,
I was,
hi Alison,
sir.
The different African elephants,
you're not,
you're not taking an African elephant.
Could look most of the elephant to see was this Jamie.
Okay.
Jammies watching.
You're like this little buffalo just,
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Elephant came over and rolled it all.
I don't give a fuck about you trying to stab him.
He is.
Oh he does.
He's killing it.
He's killing a baby.
That's how,
that's probably a full ground buffalo.
That's just a giant elephant.
Whilst he's fucking up this buffalo.
So dangerous to look it up.
Elephant stabs and kills Buffalo.
Look at Jesus Christ.
Well that's why they have tusks.
Yeah,
I mean that.
There it is.
It's really crazy when lions take a chance.
Wow.
That was the other video.
I didn't pull those three elephants killing a lion.
That elephant just crazy as shit.
They just killed crazy.
What's crazy is lines.
We'll take a chance on elephants,
which is so nuts.
Did they will take a chance to try to kill an Alpha and they'll jump on their
back.
They'll try to jack him.
Well when you go to a game reserve in South Africa,
you can't,
it has to be big enough to sustain lines cause it's super expensive cause
there's just a pride of lions will eat everything.
You got to keep replenishing the animals because they just,
they're just too effective.
We know after that dentist shot Cecil the lion and became this international
outrage,
they banned the lion hunting.
And because of that,
people didn't want to go back and they weren't getting the money from it.
So they wound up euthanizing like 200 lions because they're undulate population
was getting devastated.
But what made me think when I heard that I was like how many lines are they
killing?
Like how many people are going over there to hunt lions?
It's,
it brings him good money.
I mean weird is that a huge part of South Africa is part of the conservation
efforts or that you know,
big game you can fall,
you can hunt the big five or whatever they call it.
Yes,
that's exactly what I call it.
But it's,
but it means a lot of money.
It is a lot of money and it brings them a lot of money and it brings them a lot
of money for conservation and all that stuff.
But what a weird activity.
Is there an activity that's more human in that like,
oh,
we are so conflicted and so weird that the only way we have animals that stay
alive in this part of the world,
like whether an record populations is to set it up so you can kill him.
Yeah.
So what we figured out some weird loophole.
Look,
we don't want to rhino to die.
Hey,
we don't want to ride on a die either.
So let's go hit a bunch of them and we kill like one a week.
Come on.
And if they could get enough rhinos who they can make a case for that,
they would be doing that.
I mean,
they're doing it with lions,
are doing it with everything cause L's.
I mean all the different animals that you think of plains animals in Africa,
there are record numbers there.
Neil Guy,
they bring him back to Texas.
They're all over Texas.
Yeah.
There's so many animals there.
And a lot of those animals were on the verge of extinction.
But they're there because people kill him.
Like what a fucking he has.
No,
you're drunk.
It's weird.
The bigger issue is,
is um,
unbroken migratory range habitat.
The Masai Mara was one of the few places where they can roam for thousands of
miles,
but most of Africa now is broken up into,
I think there's an area in Cameroon or whatever,
but most of Africa is broken up into,
I mean,
in South Africa it's all basically with the exception of Kruger park,
it's all abandoned.
Um,
you know,
cattle lots and then they just,
there's money in it.
So you buy that lot and you just stock over the animals and then you drive
around.
They,
it's a sustainable ecosystem,
but it's you gotta yeah,
you gotta you still,
you do have to call the,
the,
you know,
elephant population and lion population when we think about Africa.
Right.
And when we say,
oh,
elephants are going extinct in Africa,
like Africa is so big,
it's crazy.
It's so big.
You've seen the map where this stuff,
all the countries inside of Africa,
that was so shocking to me.
I know.
Couldn't believe that.
So there could be an abundance of them in one area and none in another area.
It's like saying,
look,
they have a black bear problem in New Jersey,
which they do.
Okay.
Do that.
Yeah,
they do.
But that doesn't affect us here in California.
Like if people just started shooting black bears,
you're like,
hey man,
there's not that many of those.
Why are you shooting him?
You know,
but just a mountain lion.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
one just died,
a famous one just died.
I got a text from a Noah out here.
Um,
he,
uh,
eight,
some rat poison.
Oh Shit.
That's a real problem with rat poison man.
Rat poison doesn't just affect rats.
You know,
there's like,
there's secondary and my dog was tied that way.
And what it does is a rat poison,
I think stops you from producing vitamin K in your body,
which is,
which is how you clot blood.
So they just bleed internally.
So my dog shit load of it and they pumped his stomach,
gave him charcoal,
and then he had to take vitaminK supplements for a long time.
Yeah.
The people,
they poisoned the rats than things eat the rats,
you know?
Yeah.
And this a mountain lion,
a famous mountain lion collared wondering tracking number.
Yeah.
Rinella texted me about it and then I looked into it.
Oh you got it there.
What does,
which number does it say?
He is 47 [inaudible] 47 is not the one that they spotted at the not,
no,
this one's only three years old.
We were going to get a photo of that,
right?
Yeah,
let's do that.
Oh yeah.
We tracked it down.
Yeah.
What happened is expensive.
You know,
let's,
let's do that.
Let me know after the,
well,
which one you want an artist's proof,
whatever and we've gotten,
yeah,
that detail of it or whatever.
Yeah,
because that one photo that they caught of it,
if you seen that photo of the lion with the Hollywood sign behind it.
No,
it's amazing.
It's one of the best.
It's an,
again,
it's so fucking human cause this line has a collar on it like it's got bling on
stand in front of the Hollywood sign and it's as big as fuck is all that.
It's like 150 O'Malley.
Right.
Ah,
that's amazing.
That photo that looks stage looked staged.
By the way.
I look at the,
look at the muscles.
It's forearms.
Yeah.
That's a ridiculous animal.
That's one thing that people don't,
I don't think you've realized like that's not a spelt thing.
Like a house.
That's a lion,
sir.
They have enormous forearm.
Yeah.
It's a lion that ways bring down an elk.
I bet that's 130 pounds.
Yeah.
Maybe 150 I think about big.
That is,
that doesn't seem big,
but you see a rottweiler,
a police dog or 90 pounds.
Good luck.
Yeah,
good luck.
That's an add.
Add another 60 pounds.
40 pounds of,
that's a big animal,
man.
Yeah.
Such a big animal and they're just wandering around our neighborhoods.
Factive killers.
If I having a guy come on who's a mountain lion biologist at it,
depending on Canyon.
Oh really?
Yeah,
and I might actually go and trap one with him.
How many?
How many do they think there are quite a few.
This one like one 50 wow.
Dale,
when the died.
Wow.
Hundred and 50 is a big cat.
Jesus,
clearly three years old.
Jesus Christ.
Three years old.
He was 150 pounds.
Just living on deer.
Yeah.
Go look around for deer in California.
Good luck.
Yeah.
They know deer out here.
There's so few deer.
If you're a deer hunter in California,
your sad face all year round,
you're not looking forward to it.
And Yeah,
I see a lot of here in Topanga.
Yeah.
You see all,
they're drawn to me.
Oh,
I feed them.
Are you um,
it's my alpha energy.
They feel safe with me.
But is,
did you,
do you have a connection with them,
do you think?
To be honest with you,
I run with them.
Have you always been like this?
They flanked me.
They would never go past me.
They flagged pain.
When I do my foot and open field,
they surround me and they bow.
And until I released them and I go,
this is my favorite.
People that think that they have some sort of special couch k dog.
My friend's girlfriend,
we're all sitting around.
My friend's girlfriend Shao hot,
so hot is one of those.
Go in a sec.
We're sitting there and she goes,
and I was,
I was meditating and I saw a deer and it looked at me and 50 or gave me love.
Well,
I'm just looking at her.
I was a young,
amazing,
she's so hot.
She's so,
she's such an estrogen.
And my buddy,
of course,
you know you had this sort and can't let it go.
Let it go.
Let her have her thing.
My buddy goes,
why
that shit to me.
Explain y'all biological.
Well,
you know what,
you're close minded and you're on intuitive.
I'm really intuitive.
And it became that intuitive.
My favorite thing,
I love that shit.
But those people that claim they have some special connection with animals,
like animals just recognize I am,
they know my name,
know,
kind of schooled me,
Megan Fox.
I was doing a movie with her and,
and I assume she started talking about signs and I was making fun of like
psychics and signs and Megan goes,
well,
um,
maybe you ever think that maybe you're a little close minded.
And I go,
nope,
not scientific minded.
And no,
I'm not.
And I think all psychics are liars.
And I think astrology is bullshit.
But then like Megan literally went into her knowledge of science and geology and
everything else and I was like,
oh,
you're a fucking,
oh wait,
you're really hot intellectual and you know a shit load it and I made a judgment
on you.
It was very,
it was actually embarrassing isn't it?
And interestingly you would automatically make a judgment on who's hot.
Like ah,
your lives have an easy as fuck.
And she's not like that.
Like a judgment that you would make on the son of a rich man.
Like if someone correct grew up in is in the family business and his father was
a very successful man but he's taking over the family business,
he would assume this guy's a bitch.
Yup.
Right.
Most of the time,
most of your,
you're wrong so often that it's such a bad debt.
Yeah.
Cause like if a great,
if a great man has a son,
yeah.
Most likely he's going to teach that sons cool shit and the sun's going to have
to like live up to a certain standard.
Right.
Well that was the thing with Megan.
I would notice after I had that interaction with her,
I've known her a little bit cause I know her husband really well.
And then uh,
and then I notice that every time we wouldn't be shooting,
she'd be reading a book of substance.
Like that's what she does when she's not on set.
So I was like,
well what are you doing?
You're,
you're,
you're laying an iPhone next to your head.
What am I doing?
Their iPhone next to the other side of your head and you have these weird
conversations.
That's my favorite thing you did.
I got to start doing that again.
Do it.
Those are so funny,
man.
I do that.
Or I talked to the stunt men and ask them like how much they can bench.
You'll know what you're a navy seal.
So when you shoot,
the problem with that is invariably ends up someone pulling out mats.
And then he started,
you started a little one.
I had Paulie Malignaggi,
he was at my gym and then he kind of knew,
he goes,
wait a minute,
I just figured out what the fuck you are freaking out.
So I take that opportunity to ask him like I'm just asking him like some boxing
questions.
Next thing I know he's giving me a boxing lesson.
How fucking cool is that?
And this school,
yes,
it was three days ago.
He really gonna do that bare knuckle ball.
Yeah.
And he's taken it personally.
But man,
you don't want to break your hands.
You don't want to get your face cut up.
Cause he done fighting like boxing.
He's like,
he looked like he was in shape.
He was like,
and he was giving people pointers.
He's very,
he looks at,
he seems,
I listened to him a lot on showtime.
Stuff keeps cerebral is hell.
I mean he knows the game.
He's very smart guy.
He doesn't get hit a lot.
No.
Yeah.
Think about a boxer that can talk as well as he can.
Oh,
I'm most articulate as he is and understand.
I mean if you watch the way he fights like watches,
vice with Adrian Broner like he knew how to figure out the puzzle that's broken
his hand speed and power punching and he punches him volume.
He's always in grace.
Show me patterns,
like just basic things that I was like,
damn,
I really want to see the actual sparring match between him and Connor cause all
the gifts he released his of tracking them.
I know it's a long one.
It had to be.
There had to be some fun moments and then I will also,
I think apparently Pauley got off a plane and then he hadn't,
it wasn't even really,
he wasn't even working out that much.
Then they go,
who's going to train with them and they go,
we're going six rounds or something.
He just filming the film it.
Yeah,
that's it and they use it as a promo.
Right?
People are ruthless,
Bro.
The idea that they weren't going to use that is more ridiculous.
Come on,W who are you?
Do you don't understand how this business works?
They're promoting,
they're promoting of,
he's a Brooklyn Kid,
he's a smart guy.
Listen,
they're promoting a fight that is going to generate hundreds of millions of
dollars in revenue.
You think that they're going to spare your sense abilities,
they're going to spare your feelings and not show edited versions of you getting
popped.
But my problem is so the,
I have a problem with that all across the board because I feel like,
um,
when common decency,
fair play,
you know,
contract and ed sort of the contract,
you enter,
I'm coming out to help you out and what you're going to do is use me,
go fuck yourself.
Like it's not believing it's,
I understand.
It's a business leave.
They paid him.
I'm sure they did not believe he signed paperwork over.
Well,
I'm sure they did.
But that's a sneaky move.
It's fuck yes.
And I,
and I,
I have a problem with general.
I just don't like justifying anything because it's going to be good promotion.
I,
I'm always uneasy.
You don't have people say,
hey man,
bad press,
but you're talking about them,
but fuck off.
I completely agree with you.
However,
the play devil's advocate.
If I'm Mr businessman mister money bags that she just went in one ear and out
the other,
I don't know what you're talking about.
That's a video of some shit that actually happened.
I hate the truth of you.
If you hate the truth,
I can understand why you would want to show them that video.
Right.
But Conor did drop him,
ironically left,
and it's going to be a great fight.
Conor McGregor versus Floyd Mayweather.
And ironically,
it might've been good for Pauli in terms of it creating this fight with arts.
I mean,
you're talking about them,
although I think I didn't call him on stands on his own now,
but as an announcer.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
he's got a real name and he's a,
he's an excellent boxer.
It's,
he's probably one of the better commentators in the game,
if not the best.
Oh yeah.
Very,
very good.
100% him and Andre Ward,
Andrew Ward found my favorite and Roy Jones Jr for Joe's juniors.
Outstanding.
You had a 200 word,
like brilliant,
brilliant guy.
Brilliant guy.
Just watching him like figure out Kovalev too.
Right?
Especially in the second fight.
Unbelievable.
Yeah.
In fact,
that,
you know,
he dropped Covello with a body shot and you know,
Cola.
So they didn't give him a chance and that they just stopped the fight.
Yeah.
It didn't look like he wanted to keep going.
I felt like that way was Amir Khan.
Like if people are like,
well listen,
come here.
Con has nothing to prove.
He has an amazing record.
He's fighting a genius in Crawford and probably there's no shame in this.
He was supposed to fight,
um,
cal Brooks and he kind of went,
you know what?
This guy is gay.
He's time is on his side and he's going to,
he's kind of figured this out.
He's bigger and he's going to kidnapped.
He's going to hit me and maybe hurt me here.
I don't feel like doing this anymore.
If that was the case,
I forgive him for everything.
It's like,
I thought it was a smart decision to align them and maybe it was really hard.
He's a Hillary or the kettle and that thing is not,
but the Kell Brook
fight would have actually gotten Amir Khan more money.
It was a salad and he decided to take the fight against Crawford.
He's a real fighter.
If Crawford is not the best pound for pound fighter on earth.
He's number two.
He's one or two.
I want to see him in or I'll Spence.
Well him Earl Spencer is fantastic too.
But I think the argument of pound for pound is Loma Chanko in him.
That's the argument that those two guys are number one.
Yeah.
Who Do you think is number one?
I mean I think you're talking about Crawford.
Crawford Crawford's fought enough competition.
Like when he fights Earl Spence and I think that Lowman Chanko has probably had
more fights and you can really get into this conversation cause he hasn't,
he has less than everybody.
But he said last year he won the world title like four fights.
I,
yeah,
how many fights?
It was something ridiculous like that.
I mean he fought a world class fighters first time out though when I saw him
fight that Jorge Amazing Mexican fighter or of that that who is the guy gloss
record here is 13 and one in Crawford is 35 and hour.
Wow.
Big Difference.
But boxing is tricky that way.
Right?
So what's,
what's the level of competition is they bring you up slow?
Well,
the difference is Loma Chanko had an extensive amateur internationally,
but soda,
Crawford Crawford had a great amateur background to look Crawford the
differences Crawford's way bigger.
That's the difference.
If there were the same size would be really interesting to see what,
what happened.
But Crawford's a lot bigger than him.
He would.
Yeah.
And it's not a good fight now it's just to watch him take Reagan down and all
these amazing fighters were gone.
Deo that had gotten deal.
I thought it was Reagan now.
I don't think so.
I think announcing and French's and he gained duel Regan doe if he can gun down.
Um,
but yeah,
he did.
He just metals people.
His footwork is unparalleled.
But Terrence Crawford men,
first of all,
he's probably the best switch hitter ever next to Marvin Hagler.
He might be better.
Yeah,
I mean it's hard to say.
I he gets,
he can find you a game plan for that.
So good Orthodox then.
So good south paw,
but to watch Lenora's I said Jorge,
the Nars,
I think it's sec fighter.
And to watch him,
he knocked Lowman go down.
But then again,
like this guy figures you out.
He just,
he goes,
I know what you're doing now and then you're done.
Well,
so does Crawford.
I mean the the best.
I mean that was an interesting,
Sylvan is prime too.
He would just figure out your timing.
Yeah.
Figure out what you do,
how you enter,
where the gaps are,
where the holes are.
Okay.
I see how the key to the castle,
let's rock.
Right.
And then somewhere around the end of the first round,
Anderson would start switching stances on you and fucking doing some Bruce Lee
moves and the next thing you know,
he's got his foot and your face.
Yeah,
that's nice.
Figures you out.
It's exactly right.
These guys are just the,
the,
a really elite of the elite fighters.
They're just the best at solving the little riddle.
That is what your skills are.
Now.
How do you solve that riddle?
That is Khabib Nirvana.
This is as a different riddle because that motherfucker is not on the outside
boxing you.
And
he called her a wild Connor for a while.
You know he's going to take you down.
But what it looked like Konner for a,
it was isolating.
He had two hands on that wrist.
He was stopping him for a long time from closing his his hands and,
and that seemed kind of effective for awhile.
I mean,
good luck long road.
That's like saying you're running a marathon.
Hey,
you know he beat me in the marathon but for the first hundred yards I know
that's what it's like.
It doesn't matter because it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
As a five round fight,
keeping me from grabbing my hands for now your hands tired yet.
Hi Forum,
I'm taking you down.
Take it down.
That guy is so relentless and the skill level and the endurance level,
he has to pursue that pace for five rounds.
I don't think I even appreciate it.
I mean I can intellectualize it and I could describe it,
but I think when you're in there with him,
like when,
when he fought Edson Barboza and he had Edson Barboza up against the cage.
Come on buddy.
As mine give up.
Edson has this.
No,
that was against Michael Johnson.
Has this thousand yard stare where?
Where he's getting mauled.
Yeah.
It's just like,
he's like breathing.
He's like,
Oh fuck.
Like this is,
this is a different kind of human beings.
Those Russians are at this a different kind of human being.
Pakistanis,
so t and they grow up with fighting.
Tommy's a baby.
He's a sad culture.
They were,
they suffer a great deal.
That's the left.
He's like Jesus Christ.
What the fuck did I sign up for?
Skin mauled and I love,
I love Covey.
Looks like his legs.
His body looks like,
you know guys see at the pool kind of works out maybe a little.
It just doesn't,
it looks pretty fit.
That guy looks fit.
Barboza is really must go.
He was jacked man.
Photo of could be like making like a most muscular pose or something.
Yeah.
He's fucking pretty jazzed.
Not though.
He's just a freak.
No,
not compared to a lot of dudes.
Yeah,
go down there,
look at that.
You know,
cause he's,
he looks like a really strong grappler.
He
had is pretty good there.
Shut your,
your dirty lie spilling is,
he's pretty good.
What about that one right there.
How about that one?
Cut The shit.
You look like that.
It's basically the same if I was in there it would,
you would call it steroids.
You are always like that.
Yeah.
I was always looked at.
I say when I first met you,
I didn't even take vitamins,
Jack Tv,
you were jacked out of your mind.
It was because you lifted weights.
Well that was when I was just getting into Jujitsu.
So I really started lifting weights heavy cause I was tired of getting mauled.
So I really got into lifting welfare.
I am weak.
I'm like,
cause I'm used to striking,
striking,
so different than graph,
different in terms of the demands and your muscles and your fatigue.
Yeah.
But,
and it works the other way too because I remember I hadn't done any striking at
all in like a year.
I got done none,
zero just Jujitsu.
And then,
um,
my friend Jamie and I started doing,
Jamie,
um,
is a,
a trainer and we were doing this a training session and he had me hit mits too.
And like just hit and miss for a couple of minutes.
I was gassed out.
I was like,
how is this possible?
So we're,
I roll all the time.
I'm in good shape right now.
When you came,
we get guys who are triathletes or whatever,
they come in and uh,
Wayne,
the colic shout out to the great way.
Mcculloch my trainer who I love,
um,
I love that guy.
He's the best.
I fucking,
that's one of my favorite people in the world.
Like whenever I see him all is right in the world.
He's just a humble,
that silver medalist in the Olympics world champion and nobody asks him
questions in the gym.
It's like,
hey,
you had this gold mine,
this guy here who's beat Morales,
who fought prince not seem to the distance and nobody knows it.
And he never tells anybody.
And I'll see these guys hitting.
And I'm like,
wait,
why don't you tell them?
And he goes,
they don't ask me.
I don't,
I don't bother them.
He's just the most humble doing or like,
it drives me fucking nuts but lost.
But anyway,
we'll get like triathletes,
people who are in really good shape.
But if you,
if you're sparring and you're afraid to get hit,
you stop breathing.
And so in three minutes,
in two minutes,
I don't care how good a shape you're in,
the minute you get punched once you're like,
yeah,
it took me literally,
it probably took me three years to get over that in a way.
Cause I have no confidence as a boxer and I shouldn't.
Why is getting punched in the head?
What is going on with you?
I'm not getting punched hard.
How hard.
I mean sometimes there's a,
then my buddy Chris from Boston is a giant and heal by accident.
Sometimes you need to get connected and stuff,
but now you know,
you learn how to kind of keep your hands up.
But you're getting older.
You worry about that.
I'm insecure bro,
but are worried about your brain rattled.
I was a little cloudy.
I stopped for a little while and yeah,
so you're getting cloudy from getting hit.
I don't know.
I said to Brendan and I said,
you know,
he has no time for this shit.
He gets so mad at me.
He just goes,
you're older.
What are you doing?
Oh,
you're getting that look like.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's what happens.
So keep that shit up,
man.
He storms off.
Yeah.
Well he,
he came to the realization,
you know,
he'd duck.
He ducked yet he was,
oh,
I don't know.
He was shame car went all the time.
Mark Gordon,
all those guys and throwing up after,
after his training sessions and he played football forever.
I'll be all right.
Yeah.
Well he quit though at the right time.
It's really did.
Yes he did.
I mean,
he's fun.
Yes.
He,
he made it out at the right time.
So invested in him like,
like he's my,
my brother's.
So whenever he talks about CRT,
I'm like,
see I CTM.
Like now you're okay.
Don't worry about it because your doctor,
you're fine.
I promise it's not going to happen.
I don't like to think about it.
Well,
I mean he's,
he's honest.
If he wasn't doing good,
he tell you,
you know,
if he wasn't feeling good,
he sorry.
True.
I think everybody needs someone who they
trust implicitly,
that they,
that can pull the cord on them and to tell them,
hey man,
yeah,
you got to stop getting hit.
Yes.
And for young fighters,
man,
it is such a hard decision to make.
I've talked to several guys who had to sell their fighter,
several trainers that have to tell their fighters to retire and it's never easy.
It's never easy.
And some tribal identity,
the fighter will leave and go with a different trainer and be successful and,
and the the,
you know,
and this one case,
the trainer was like,
I wish him well.
I mean I'm sure he can still beat guys.
That's not the problem.
The problem is he showing some obvious signs of deterioration mentally,
neurologically,
the way he moves,
the way he talks and a good a person cares about.
She was going to go,
okay,
we had a lot of fun.
It was a great run.
You're fine right now.
Like you can talk and we can treat whatever problems come up.
Apparently CBD is fantastic for that for a lot of people with brain issues.
And a lot of the inflammation issues because of trauma.
There's a lot of stuff they do magnetic stuff that hasn't gone.
Oh,
did you went down to San Diego and soldiers where they put the electronics guys
doing that right now.
Seal Guy,
but I don't think I've ever met a fighter who's retired who doesn't still feel
like they could fight for the belt.
Oh yeah.
They all want to get,
even chuck Liddell,
when he did fight and the kid was like,
I'd like to throw my hat in there against Jon Jones.
I'm a pretty good wrestling.
Like he was already 48 yeah,
but you never lose that.
Part of what makes you a great fighter and a killer is that that sort of love of
the game.
If you ask Polly model nausea right now,
I guarantee,
I guarantee if you're like,
could you fight for a title right now?
He goes,
I thought put my hat in there.
Yeah.
Fighters like that.
Of course.
That's why they're,
I mean,
that's why they become successful in the first place.
If you think about how you are when you first start out,
even if you're like real athletic,
you're fucking terrible,
you know you're hitting the bag,
your,
your feet are off.
Even if you hit it hard,
like you're doing something wrong and you're clumsy,
you're wide open afterwards,
there's something that someone who's really good,
we'll expose and then eventually you learn skills and as you learned skills,
you see those holes,
you tighten all those holes up and then he become far better than you are.
But the only reason why you you can do that is because you think you're a bad
motherfucker from the jump,
but you hit that bag higher and you'll look here,
I'm going to fuck everybody up.
And you start believing that.
And then as you get skills like Jesus,
I'm glad I didn't get into a real fighter.
He's a real fighter early on because that is one of the most insidious things
that trainers do.
They'll throw their fighter to the wolves,
like they'll set their fighter up with some young up and coming phenom who's
just smashing people and it's hard to get them fights and they'll get this guy
to fight them because this is a few guys that'll just fight anybody.
Oh my God.
And they've only been doing it for like a year.
You're going to take that fight against it.
You just kind of 16 to know.
Oh look,
she has brothers.
When they went into the,
into Andre Ward's camp in Oakland,
they were banging.
Yeah.
And I'm sure from day one,
yeah,
cause I was talking to Nate Diaz.
I was like,
but you guys go light.
He goes,
no,
we'd bang.
Bang.
Yeah.
I talked to Joe Schilling about that the first time you ever met nick.
And he's like,
uh,
he's talking to Nick's friends.
Nick's like,
okay,
you got a cup,
you've got your mouth.
And then Joe said to Nixon and goes,
we fighting?
He goes,
yeah.
all right.
Which is fine.
She just knew like this is going to be fighting.
This is not.
It's like,
well,
we sparring and we fighting.
Yeah.
And they,
they want to fight it.
I think as you get better and better at it,
it probably becomes addictive and she's for sure because every time I go in
there and I go,
I'm not going to spar.
But then there's somebody and then you say,
well we'll just move around,
but then we'll see all salt also testing each other too,
right?
Yeah.
Like nick is world class fighter Joe shillings,
world chance.
I hope boxer strikings evil still showing as evil.
He fucks people be standing next to him too.
He's also just big.
It's big,
long and athletic.
He's just like,
Oh God,
it's doing very well in MMA now as he really got nasty fucking ground and pound
his last fight man.
When you got a guide that that good at slashing people with elbows and,
and punching people and you get him on top of you,
the ground and pound is on another level,
you know,
because they can generate serious power in short distances like a lot of
grapplers have a hard time with like,
do you remember when cro cop got on top of consomme and opened his face up with
an elbow and it was horrific,
but it was inside the guard.
Yeah,
but you,
you are real good striker.
A short amount of distance.
You,
Brendan said that's the strongest guy he's ever felt comp.
Yeah,
it's strong motherfucker,
man.
Powerful.
Those ridiculous legs does,
does legs.
It belongs on a fucking elephant and a fun day,
you know?
Oh,
so going back to this asteroid impact,
I'm sorry,
there is a layer somewhere around 66 million years ago that indicates that the
Earth got hit by an asteroid.
That's what I mean.
I think it's the layers high in your radium.
I think an iridium has a,
it's very rare on earth,
but very common in space.
And there's a bunch of other indications that that's the time that it hit,
but what they're saying,
the radio lab one is that the current state of understanding is that the
dinosaurs and basically most things died within the first couple of hours,
like all the dinosaurs,
they were all apparently their,
their bones or their fossils are in that iridium layer a lot of times.
Right?
I Dunno,
maybe.
Yeah.
They found a lot of,
they find them before too.
Right?
They don't just don't find any after it's Carnegie's.
Yeah.
They think that their blood boiled in their body.
They think you've got so hot that during the few hours it got to like 700 a
thousand degrees,
1200 degrees.
It's just got insanely hot.
Stand up and stay in shape.
Now I gotta worry about fucking,
that's a fulltime job.
Raise my kids.
That's what we really should be thinking about.
Not just how bad were fucking the earth out,
but how bad something can fuck the earth fell from the sky.
Yeah.
That's what we really should be attention to.
Instead of paying attention to so many nonsensical things that people
concentrate on,
there's a real chance that we could get hit in our lifetime with something that
ends civilization like that.
Yeah.
100% can happen.
I had Graham Hancock on last week and we were going over his new book,
this book.
Um,
whereas it isn't it right here,
Jamie.
It's right there.
It's fucking,
it's excellent.
And Graham was talking about to call the America before.
It's the evidence of,
um,
civilizations in,
in the Americas,
in North America is particularly in the Amazon that they think that there was
millions of people live in the Amazon.
But when the European explorers came over here,
the game smallpox and wiped out everyone and they came back hundreds of years
later and there was nothing like the,
the entire civilization.
I feel like the 1492 there was a,
I think when the Spanish came up through the Mississippi Delta,
the same thing.
Yeah,
same thing.
Yeah.
They wiped out 90.
But like a lot of people think that the genocide of the native Americans was
just European soldiers and and people and settlers killing native Americans,
which did happen,
but it was [inaudible].
90% of them were killed by disease,
90% the entire population.
They even had Dave and had certain government policies where they're like,
do you missionaries are going out there and trying to convert them to
Christianity?
You're giving them your diseases.
They knew that back then.
They knew that they were like,
you're,
you're there.
They're getting sick and they're dying of,
you know,
there were all of a sudden they were like,
we're getting these colds and people are dying.
They didn't have any resistance to that.
Crazy.
It does dirty Europeans with their shit.
Water shoots outside their house and fucking vermin running around.
That was war of the worlds.
Remember war of the worlds.
That movie that just,
how did they die?
They weren't ready for pathogens.
That's my whole philosophy on we all try to be tough.
One of the things about all of us as men or anybody is we hate to be vulnerable.
So you know,
I trained and I,
I stay in shape,
I eat well and won't last forever.
I don't think there's anything such thing as,
I don't think you can be really ready for a situation,
you know,
in a bar I guess.
And then you get bit by a tick mean you get a flesh eating disease and you'd
die.
Sure.
So I don't know if she has any way to get merged with yourself.
Well,
I mean you can protect yourself,
but you are ultimately very vulnerable.
But then this video lab,
what was freaking me out about was that there's so many of those things floating
around the sky.
I mean this is what Graham talked about in not just this book,
but in previous books that they think that something slammed into the earth
somewhere in the past that ended the ice age probably wiped out a giant chunk of
the large megafauna on North America led to the almost instantaneous extinction
of so many different animals.
And so it goes,
yeah.
And so it goes and it can happen again.
That could be a super volcano.
There's all kinds of stuff like that.
All these fucking things and it makes you want,
if announced asteroid was going to hit Denver,
NASA was practicing that this week.
Damn tend to Dennis before they've had like a practice run using a bunch of the
different,
uh,
here's the practice run getting the boat go to Australia.
Exactly.
I have to go pee.
Go Pee.
Hold My,
you've got to go to a to talk about me being,
I'm talking about you in Miami.
Yeah.
May 9th 10th 11th at the Improv.
And then Orlando
promote me.
Okay.
Bryan County is going to be in Miami at the Improv and in Orlando.
If you go to Brian,
count.com it'll have all that stuff.
I just ran across this too on the screen on Twitter.
What happened to that?
To Ted?
God having an affair with a woman and her husband came home early,
tried to escape through the window but ended up falling on a metal beam.
Oh my God.
It went through his head.
How'd they get the beam off?
They had to saw the Bema probably.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
I just saw the pictures and what the fuck is that?
It's trying to find it.
Oh my God,
he's alive.
There's pictures of this happening in the past to Jesus Christ that got one eye
because of it.
Oh my God.
I went through his head.
Yeah,
it's weird.
What would people,
how people survive from injuries bottomy.
Yeah.
When they stopped doing those,
we haven't really talked about too much,
but I remember looking it up.
It just would dig a hole right through your eye and scramble your brain at the
metal piece of metal
and they did that because you were just too annoying.
I don't know why these people were crazy.
They would just do it.
They were doing them up until like 19 in the 1,910 down.
I'll know if it stopped like the 50s or forties the exact time,
but what do you think they're doing now besides circumcision that people are
going to look back on like that and go,
what the fuck were they thinking?
What do you think they're doing now?
Um,
I know it's just we keep learning different strategies to fix stuff.
Yeah,
that's true.
But the,
but the lobotomies not even a strategy to fix stuff.
It's like chaos your worse though.
In some cases it must have had to have,
but maybe it stopped them from being super violent or something.
Controlling people would probably be bullets.
Bullets.
I mean,
I don't know.
Why do they give someone a low bottom?
He like,
what is the,
what's the chief reason for give it someone a lithotomy.
What would you guess?
Psychosis.
Crazy stuff.
Yeah.
That they didn't have an answer probably for pharmaceuticals back then.
So they just said fucking scramble the brain somehow.
It's fucked up to me that it's still,
your brain would still work.
It's a neurological treatment of a mental disorder that involves severing the
connections between the brain's prefrontal cortex.
You made it too big.
You're interviewing
most of connections to and from the prefrontal cortex.
The anterior part of the frontal lobes of the brain are severed.
What did they do that for Brian?
Um,
because when you had a personality that was when you were crazy,
they would take out the part of your brain,
I guess that was reactive and the gauge you essentially a personality.
So when you were on the bottom ISED you are really kind of a normal person.
Have you ever seen the movie Francis?
They gave her Labatt me.
Well look at this.
He went crazy on the bottom line.
It's a little kid.
They did it to a little kid.
Yeah.
Horrifying.
Why they do it to that little kid scramble your brain.
Terrible mind.
If I remember right,
there was one guy he was doing up to like 70 a day.
There's something like that that's free an hour.
Yeah.
That's what they,
other day long,
I think it would help you.
You know,
I'm reading,
uh,
this Guy David [inaudible]
oh
shit.
But there were people who,
you know,
they had electric shock therapy and they were,
they were crazy and they would try all these things.
Tonic,
schizophrenia.
She says she has look at her smiling 16th months later they would try these
things.
So before and after it.
So it worked.
The little bottom,
we were,
she just smile and everywhere.
Yeah,
but she would smile.
She saw a baby get run over by a car.
She'd smile.
She saw her house catch on fire.
Jesus,
the brain,
sort of like that Guy David Epstein who wrote,
he wrote the sports gene.
We found the fastest people in the world,
tiny part of Africa,
and the people that run the farthest,
which is the highlands of Kenya,
really fascinating book.
He's a sports illustrated writer and then he,
there's a new book coming out called range and a,
it's about how when you teach a kid or when you,
when you learn a lot of different disciplines,
so if you're some of the best violinists,
some of the best athletes,
whatever,
they didn't specialize.
It's very,
it's,
it's probably a bad idea to specialize from a very early age with the exception
is like tiger woods.
He compares tiger was and Roger Federer.
Tiger Woods was raised to be a golfer from the agent to his dad was already
having them.
He was watching,
having them watch how he swings and everything and Roger Federer,
greatest tennis player ever was playing in the music,
playing soccer at plant,
anything with a ball and didn't really get into tennis,
didn't really find his love of tennis until he was in his teens.
And a lot of musicians,
great musicians who are innovative.
So whether it's Duke Ellington or whatever,
those are great ones who make original music.
A lot of them are self taught and a lot of them played a lot of instruments
until they started to focus on that one instrument that spoke to them.
And he uses all these different examples of how how generalizing and doing a lot
of different things informs essentially informs your ability to become really
good at one thing when you finally decided to do that.
And it's a really kind of cool because a lot of parents are specializing.
A lot of parents,
I can play baseball,
that's what we're gonna play camp and everything else.
We're just going to practice that bad idea.
Bad idea according to this,
with the exception of very few skills like golf,
but everything else is you want to really expose your kid to a wide variety of
things because for whatever it does with those that you know,
all the neurons and stuff you,
you are,
you're able to get better at something when you're practicing another thing.
Well that makes sense to me.
It also makes sense to me that you'd want to get your kid exposed to a lot of
things to find out what they actually enjoy.
Cause sometimes you enjoy something and you go all,
but I don't enjoy as much as this.
You find some new thing that's even better,
but I'm sure you went through things like that.
Right.
But a lot of parents,
like a lot of,
he was talking about Tiger Moms,
they'll cheat.
They'll say you have a choice.
You're playing the violin and you're playing the piano and you're not playing
any other instrument.
We're going to get better at that.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Well the problem is it doesn't,
it stifles innovation.
It.
You become really pedantic and good at following instructions,
but you're not going to be very innovative.
You'll be really technically good,
but you also want to be naughty and you wind up sacrament shit like Yo yo Ma
was,
he would try,
he tried a bunch of different instruments until he finally said,
I'm going to play this.
Yeah,
you want to be nodding.
You want to fight it.
You wanna fight mommy and you probably have some weird mommy porn bookmarks.
There's amazing amounts of stepmom porn.
Really.
It's all step step-mom's.
Well,
porn like mom,
your father's going to be so mad at you.
Well,
mom,
mom or a derivative of mom is,
I think the second most typed in word in porn hub.
Something to do with young,
but,
but mom is nothing.
Granny porn is huge in Kenya and the UK.
Do you know why they think because you're raised by an older lady or an older
man,
your headmaster,
there is a position of authority and as you're exhaling to,
well as you're coming to and you're formulating your point of view of the world
and making sense,
you tend to sexualize whatever's in front of me.
I guess that makes sense.
You in print so,
so guilty and you know that's Kinda,
she grandma's.
I'd like to fuck what kind of world we live in and my friend's wife,
he catches her watching grandma porn.
Gray,
gray,
old men,
Bang and gals.
He's into that.
She runs the old dude.
She didn't know old guys like,
like real old.
Your body looks like warm cheese.
Understand?
Why would they like that?
I don't.
It's who the fuck knows.
That is a weird thing though,
that you hear that some women like really old guys.
So you don't hear that from women or from men rather.
Yeah.
What does it say?
The world's news photos.
I bet she was hot as fuck back in the 80s 100% yeah,
we're going to do listen man.
Old Hose.
They're just hosed.
It got old.
Look at that one.
I had a friend who was super macho,
didn't show that on the screen.
Let me see you,
son of a bitch who has that some,
no,
don't,
don't.
Poor Lady.
Correct.
Grandma was ridiculous.
Fake boobs.
Yeah,
and my friend that my friend,
he was,
he was from would've.
Why?
Super Macho and he was like,
he had didn't have a lot of money and he had like he would,
he was kind of a Gigolo.
He was having sex with this woman because she's old.
She's old.
I said that.
I go,
what?
She looked like when she's naked.
It's a disaster.
Disaster.
Hey,
can,
I can't look to her when she go.
So it was about the room.
I'll have to look,
you know over because yes,
it has to be no light because it's a disaster.
Why is he doing that?
He goes,
he goes by,
you know when she looks at me,
know last,
she's young.
She's me.
I go like this,
you know?
Yeah.
The ice or ice didn't make me heart.
I forget this.
I was like,
well,
some people are really into people being really into that.
Yeah.
She just wants to be admired.
I,
I've known some women like that who are into dating trolls,
trolls,
because they've never had a woman like that.
And they're like,
don't fuck.
And they're just nervous or had a friend like that to her friend was only into
guys that she knew she could do better.
Oh,
that's fantastic.
She wanted that.
She wanted them to worshiper.
Well,
there's that.
There's that.
Apparently there's a psychology where a lot of men will overfeed their wives and
get them super fat so that they don't step out on them.
Oh,
there's a lot of this is subconscious behaviors that go on top.
Why are people so God damn crazy,
I don't know.
Trauma,
you know what I call young?
Is it the Carl Young,
uh,
fucking that line that says that,
which we don't work out in our subconscious.
We will act out as fate in our lives.
How about that?
Cause you will relive patterns.
You'll relive trauma.
You will relive these patterns and you'll do it on your own terms.
And you'll wonder why you keep fuck.
Why do you keep dating the same person?
Why do you keep falling into the same problem?
Why after two years is this go bad?
What?
What is that?
Well,
there's a way to actually creatively at least sit with that and observe it and
be aware of it.
That's what therapy does.
Cause you make the unconscious conscious,
it will direct your life and you will call it fate.
What a great quote.
Wow.
Until you make the unconscious conscious.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of fucking strings pulling on.
You will direct your life and you will call it fate.
Knowing your own darkness is the best method for dealing with the darkness of
other people.
Niches.
Idea was like,
look man,
you can add these false models of life,
which is a lot of times life is a bitch,
right?
And you're not going to,
you're not going to be able to compete or you don't want it.
So what you'll do is you'll go,
it's okay.
Meek will inherit the earth.
That's all right.
I am the have money.
But is he happy?
Is He happy?
You know,
there's a lot.
We make all of us do this.
We make excuses to not live our best life.
And he was like,
Nah,
live dangerously.
And uh,
try to be the best you can be.
Just work your ass off and if you have to die,
if you have to take risks and die,
leave a good looking corpse.
Is the idea of turn your life into a fucking circus?
Do you think the meek will inherit,
inherit the earth?
You think if that was a prophecy that they would be talking about technologists,
there would be talking about like the people that run Twitter and Google and
Facebook and the Internet tech people,
which is,
if you think about like the amount of money that Facebook has,
the amount of money that youtube has.
So like these,
these enormously influential tech companies.
Even Amazon,
right?
Yeah.
Like who,
who are they?
Who are they?
These are nerds.
They're nervous.
They're very aggressive merits and they're very thoughtful nerds.
They're very competitive nerds.
So I don't consider them the mic,
I think.
I think who's the meat?
So I think the meek,
the philosophy behind that.
And I and I,
and I think the United States also works on this premise in a sense is the
American dream.
So what keeps the masses from rising up and taking the money from people who
died the have nots from taking money from the haves and especially when the
halves,
you know,
are,
are rather slim in number in comparison to the large proportion of the
population that has say that's $500 in the bank.
Well,
what's great about the United States,
what's always worked about the United States and we just,
we don't have these,
the French revolution in this country is because the American dream is about
potential.
There is a potential,
I may not have money now,
but I may and I will because I know I will because I'm an optimist.
I will be in the 1% eventually I got an idea,
bro.
I'm telling you that's a great idea and people need that hope.
You take that hope away,
you take the ability,
you take the idea that there's no way I can ever esteem out of my condition.
You better be careful.
That's what that's,
that's so potential.
The potential will be better.
The potential to be wealthier.
That think about how all of us,
a lot of us is where as we get older,
the meek will inherit the earth.
Man.
I think it's an area that people that aren't creating war was probably the
people that were leftover.
So I take it the wacky.
I think it's a way of getting people to at least live with the fact that I'm a
surf.
I'm a peasant.
I have no way to steam out of my condition,
but at least I have the afterlife.
At least I know that if I live and I suffer well and I suffer quietly and I
suffer with dignity,
there will be a reward after this.
What is the conventional definition or the conventional meaning to that
statement?
The meek will inherit the earth.
Like what or how to scholars interpret that?
Well,
religious,
right,
right.
But I mean,
how do they,
how do they interpret that?
What does,
I think it was in the same van as it's harder for a camel to pass to the,
and I have a needle than a rich man to enter the Kingdom of heaven.
So,
so you know that the famous story where when a Christ did you want to follow me
to the rich guy,
he said give up all your money and the rich guy turn hung his head and walked
away and he said,
poor guy.
It's so hard for the,
for the rich to get to give up their life of privilege.
It's very difficult.
Do you think Jesus was a real person?
Historically?
I think there was probably a rabbi named Jesus of Nazareth,
Nazareth.
That's what,
that's what that seems to be the conclusion among a lot of historians and he was
a radical rabbi.
He was a radical man cause he's simplified Judaism is really what he was.
He was simplifying Judaism to say,
look,
you know,
you could follow the book of Leviticus and all the rituals it takes to become a
good Jew,
which is there's a certain way at a quarter a calf and there's a certain way,
certain things you can eat and you have to bathe and you have to do all these
rituals,
and he said,
way too complicated.
We're never going to spread the word this way.
He said,
just make it simple.
Do it.
Rabbi Hillel said in the Old Testament,
do unto others as you'd have them do onto you and hold only one.
God is your God fathers,
so that we're all the idea of a monolithic God is that there's a,
there's one father,
we're all brothers and sisters.
That way we're all have the same moral worth that way.
I can't judge you that way.
I don't know what you're worth.
Only God does.
I Dunno.
I don't know where you have,
I don't know what your value is.
You're a human being.
I can't quantify that.
I think.
I think that's a beautiful thing.
I think we all benefit from that religious and that Judeo Christian idea whether
we know it or not.
And if you want to replace that,
my only issue with atheists is if you want to try to replace that irrational
idea,
that irrational idea that we're all the same moral worth.
Cause you can't prove it.
But if you're mathematically or biologically,
but what are you gonna replace that with rationality.
You want to try it?
You want to,
you want to run a law society on rationality.
You can't do that.
Well if that's the most dangerous idea works,
it's still the most dangerous idea in the world because ethics have to be
predicated.
There's gotta be bedrock idea in the world.
Well,
cause let me give you an example.
It's very rational mathematically to suggest that anybody who is mentally
handicapped is draining resources from our gifted children.
And I'm telling you now in a lot of history would if we live in abundance around
new people,
to take care of the people that are handicapped because abundance doesn't always
last.
And you can't predict the buttons and here right now,
not really.
Not for a lot of people right here.
It'd be,
it'd be very easy to justify.
If you were just prayed to the god of rationality,
it'd be very easy to justify it.
And people have done this in history,
which is what I worry about.
Sure.
Hey,
let's get rid of all the people that are draining our resources because they're
not,
they're hopeless anyway.
People on breathing machines,
people who are severely retarded,
whatever,
they are severely handicapped.
They're draining resources.
I know you love him,
but listen,
we need this money for over here.
You're in a hospital,
you're taking money,
the very old,
the very informed.
You think we need religion to keep you from taking people off?
Flexport well,
I will say that I think religion and specifically the Judeo Christian ethic and
I include Islam in that.
Um,
and by the way,
I mean Buddhism is all,
it talks about the sacredness of the ascension being these,
these religions are there because,
and I think we benefit from it.
I think that all of them,
I mean,
where does our justice system is predicated?
It's predicated on the idea that all men are created equal.
Do we benefit from it?
But there's also real problems with it.
Of course,
real problems with any ideas that'd be careful in what you understand is why you
think you can't be replaced with logic and reason.
Because logic and reason,
it has pitfalls.
But you're as good as nothing logical.
Hold on.
You see,
assuming their logic and reason doesn't also have compassion.
So like you wouldn't have compassion for the people that are mentally
handicapped.
It does.
It's too fickle.
What I'm trying to say is this,
there's something very irrational and very religious about the idea that all men
are created equal.
Then we hold these truths to be self evident that all men are created equal.
Right?
And you belt Herrara talks about this brilliantly and this book,
which is that you cannot prove mathematically or biologically that,
that the idea that all men are created equal does that sees the ends or the new
sapiens is,
is real.
Right?
So,
so because we're not,
again,
Lebron James,
if you standing next to me isn't,
we're not equal as much chocolate avatar.
Right?
So,
but we inherently know that our humanness,
our,
uh,
Schuman se are not equal physically.
He's a super athlete.
But I'm funny or I have my own suck if he went on stage and murdered.
But there are like Eddie Murphy 2.0 there are people that are better.
But what suck though,
if he was Lebron James and he was funnier than you,
well he's not a bad actor.
I'll tell you that action.
Imagine if he was really funny.
Like if you couldn't follow him,
that's when I give him my girl.
He imagined that though I would present him with,
my girl has a six foot,
what?
11 six nine six nine six foot,
two 65 bill like a god faster than everybody and stronger than amazing and
murders on stage at the store.
And when you eat the mic you have to go like this to get some like bring it down
to you because you have to go on after him.
And that's when I say to him,
he's got into the mix down.
It's fucking seven feet in the air.
And I go,
Mr Mr. James,
I'd like to be a traveling concubine.
I'm probably not want that.
I'm not your type.
No.
Then you're useless.
Take Culinary.
I'll take,
let me cook for,
you know he's got people that shut the fuck up.
That carry the bag.
Polish your shoes too annoying man.
What are you going to do?
You'll stare at his dick all day to connect.
Ask them questions about what a man he is.
Yeah.
This is weird.
What do you squat?
Leave him alone.
Okay,
I'll just be in the corn.
Write better jokes.
Just sir,
I'd like to be,
that would be so embarrassing.
Like if a guy was that good at basketball,
but then it was like a natural at comedy fair,
there are starting to murder in their nominee like,
or like a fighter.
Like what if Terrence Crawford tell him to be the funniest fucking dude in the
world.
Imagine.
Imagine,
you know,
and,
and he not just fucks people up in the ring,
but then Terrance Crawford starts doing sets the comedy store and murdering and
he's got a Netflix special and he's murdering and you're like,
oh,
here we go.
So good at these.
I don't know man.
Yeah,
but listen,
there are people that are better and everything sometimes.
I mean there are,
well there's death look,
but Elon Musk is a good example of that.
How many fucking things can that guy do at once?
But at the same time,
what I'm saying is that you can't quantify human being because you don't know
what their potential is and you don't know where the strong like
Lebron James Murders on stage,
he's not dead or than you.
He's better than you and everything fucking bird following you.
You got to follow him.
He's gonna murder and then the king has left the building.
Lacey going to drop the mic and walk away and they have problems and then you
got to go on after.
You can't be that good at,
at two fingers.
Right.
I mean,
wow.
Who says
which do you put it like three times.
Listen to me.
What if he puts the kind of effort that he puts into getting good at basketball
and he couldn't?
Good at stand up.
Awesome.
Yeah.
One muscles,
Lazy.
One muscle doesn't really write and work and like for the amount of hours that
we work on our craft versus about a basketball player as to practice staff rent
lizard.
This is Blake Griffin.
He's been trying to just stand up in the off season last couple of years more.
When he was living in La,
he got traded to Detroit now,
so it's,
it's a little bit harder for them probably,
but not yet competent to doing good.
He's good.
Yeah.
I mean from what I've heard from a few people have seen it.
That's hilarious.
Videos of it.
There you go motherfucker.
Yet so he can look at six 10 standup doesn't care.
It's a long road in 10 years.
Can work though some if he does it.
Let's see.
What I'm saying is like you take a guy who has the kind of discipline and work
ethic that an athlete does at a highest level of the game.
Yeah.
And apply that standup comics.
I bet they'll get further than a lot of us.
He's only 30 only 30 baby.
What are you going to do Blake Griffin's get to a murder in front of you.
Match a weird muscle standard of weird muscle.
Joey Diaz isn't exactly like Joey Diaz.
Hi,
bye bye.
Noon.
But he's funny as fuck.
And he's like,
he's way before noon.
Comedy's a weird thing.
Comedy is a very,
there are some flops.
Joey Diaz,
Mike at high all the time.
That mother fucker works on exact.
Joey works and is,
it's a mindset you're always writing.
Joey Diaz is a pro.
Like people see Joey and they see that,
you know,
he smokes a lot of weed and he's crazy and they assumed that he just gets up
there just rants and raves.
No,
no,
no.
That guy always has new material.
I'll always work.
Always working on something.
Yeah.
He's,
I think that's what it takes to,
I think that,
um,
this kid was younger and he told me he hadn't written a joke in two years and I
went,
well,
you're talking like a loser.
You know,
you,
you can't,
I think standup,
relentless.
Especially do you develop a follow with you?
If that's where he's at,
he's probably depressed.
There's something probably wrong with it.
We talked about that too.
Yeah,
but I'm saying that,
you know,
again,
depression is a very real thing,
but I always send it kinda younger people who've seen like they're in a Rut.
I too,
I'm a huge believer in just,
just take the steps of getting better at one type of language.
Start.
It doesn't matter if it's a guitar,
it doesn't matter.
Just get better at one little thing.
Just start practicing.
It'll motivate you to do other things.
I'm not saying depression.
Clinical depression is a very real thing.
I don't know enough about it.
Well,
the thing is,
it's,
it is real,
but it's different with every person.
It's like,
it's one of the rarest of diseases in that like you really can't put it on a
scale.
You spectrum,
you feel like shit or you don't feel like shit,
you're depressed or not depressed.
But what,
what level depressed are you,
are you suicidal?
Are you just like kind of Shitty?
Could you fix it with like running or,
or do you need like real chemical intervention and in,
do you know,
do you know the difference?
Like w what's your community like what are your friendships like?
Yeah,
what does your family life?
She was questions,
huge questions.
And by the way,
how are you eating?
How are you exercising?
What is your community like?
These are things where the,
and people who live the longest and the side is what does it,
Spain,
I heard,
and I don't know if I'm right,
has the longest per capital lift people right now and yet huge alcohol and
tobacco consumption.
But they are connected to community.
They're there and they do a lot of that.
They getting it in,
you know,
taking cs as long lunch thing and yes,
in it out.
Yes.
Drinking red wine.
Why not enjoying their life and that success and sings.
I've done.
I bet that was this Spain to lead Japan and global life expectancy go us
continued to slide because we're eating shitty food and we're getting fat.
We're also isolated.
Yeah.
There's a price you paid for as a capitalist,
as a capitalist,
as somebody believes in the free market,
there's a price you pay for the praying to the god of consumption and progress.
There is,
as we as we are,
ruthlessly competitive Americans,
real Americans are fucking ruthlessly competitive and insanely aggressive.
Football is a game of war.
It's simulated work.
You're,
you're,
you're capturing territory and everything else it,
we are so aggressive that way and look,
it makes us a great country.
We also pay a price for it,
no question about it.
It's like I get,
I do get sort of the notion that we need there.
There is this idea that we're the left,
a lot of the left says,
look man,
this,
this capitalism stuff that seems to be creating isolation and depression.
Like how's it going?
Is there,
is there a conversation that we had about how we figure out how we structure our
lives,
where community takes more of a precedence where job security,
it takes more of a presence,
all these things.
Well then I start to freak out.
I know what you're saying.
Yeah.
The,
here's the thing about socialism.
Socialism in general sounds like a terrible idea because a lot of people are
lazy and because it d incentivizes people from action and there's a certain
thing that people should have motivation to succeed.
They should have some drive and they get some satisfaction out of achieving
goals and those are all things that I would not want to deny any young person
from.
I think those,
those are really important things for happiness and one of the things that
they've,
they've studied when they've studied happiness and people,
people that are goal oriented and that set,
they set goals and achieve those goals.
It's one of the best markers for happiness and it doesn't necessarily mean
money.
You know?
The problem is we like to think of it as money as it's a money thing,
but in athletics and art,
when p it without finance attached to it at all,
when people set out to do something and then do it,
they achieve a sense of self worth and happiness.
And then understanding,
understanding of yourself,
who you are.
This is what's missing from a lot of people.
And again,
I'm not a clinical psychologist.
I don't really understand depression.
I don't,
I don't suffer from it.
But I,
I've known enough people that have to know that there's a lot of different kinds
of it.
It's all different.
And I think some people just have,
they have a broken brain.
There's something wrong in there.
And it would be nice if there was a chemical that could fit into that slot and
fix it.
And sometimes there is for those people and sometimes it changes their lives.
And then I've known people that were on the wrong metrics,
like Ari was on probation,
it was fucking with him.
It gave him depression,
you know.
And sometimes people,
they'll change their diet.
And you know,
one of the things that are Rhonda Patrick was she posted something,
I think it was on her Twitter account and how inflammation um,
led to impulsive decision making led to cheating on your diet and lead to a poor
decisions in terms of like overall lifestyle just from having higher levels of
inflammation.
So eating shitty food,
not getting enough sleep,
drinking all those things lead to inflammation.
All those things cause you to make more impulsive food choices,
shitty food choices,
bad dietary choices,
bad lifestyle and rest choices.
Like they're all,
it almost like inflammation wants more of it.
Here it is.
Study finds an inflammation even at subclinical levels in healthy participants
may provoke impulsive behavior and an inability to delay gratification.
Isn't that amazing?
Yeah.
I start to pull back with all this stuff and I always think to myself like I
think I think what you and I are after,
like when the reason I'm happy and the reason I feel so fulfilled is I'm able to
express myself fully.
Like fully.
Like I told you the other day,
like I certain development in my life.
Like I was like,
I,
I want radical honesty in the sense that I don't have to lie about anything.
I don't want to lie about anything.
I want to be very honest.
You and I have been always been so honest with each other.
Right?
And well,
that's why we know each other's so.
Yes.
And the minute we started fucking bullshitting and you're like,
oh,
like do what?
But that,
that's where you have your friends and hold you accountable because they know
exactly who you are.
And it's very important.
Exactly.
But that,
so,
so what that allows you to do is to express yourself fully and completely.
The original self expression is my home,
my credo,
my idea.
But,
but so eating well,
if eating well,
see,
I don't want my body to get in the way.
I don't want it to get in the way.
So I investigate how to feel optimal so that I can just not have to get in the
way and I can do the things I love.
Yeah.
That is a form of,
of expressing myself fully.
I always wanted a box.
I'm so,
it was such a mystery to me and I'll be,
I'm nervous today because I've got to go spar some.
Fuck.
How long have you been doing it now?
How many years?
Almost five years now.
But,
but,
but I don't care about,
you know,
I'm not going to enter,
I'm not going to,
Wayne wants me to fight.
I want you to find it,
but I'm not going to do I want to,
I want to,
uh,
I don't want to be an actor.
It Taxify,
it's hilarious to me just doing that to you because he's a fighter and he's a
maniac.
He couldn't get in there lace at the gloves and his one time you can fight,
you can fight.
So the old left right left and then I put on head gear and he just puts in a
mouthpiece and it's just gives me up.
He puts his gloves wherever he wants,
which is annoying.
But,
but my point is that I,
I feel like I'm expressing myself in that vein.
I always wanted to do it on your shoulders.
They're like,
right pomegranates.
Really?
You're okay.
I have a beautiful body and doesn't bother you at all.
Boxing doesn't injure you.
It's Jujitsu and crossfit.
That shit if you're not careful.
Yeah.
I'm old now.
I have warm up.
Boxing can definitely still injure you.
Do you,
um,
do warm up with like bands?
What do you do?
You know,
I just,
you know what?
I really,
honestly,
what I do,
I have my whole dynamic stretching routine I do in the morning when I walk into
the gym,
I lace them up and I just started moving very slowly.
I warm my body up,
I start hitting them.
It's really lightly.
And as I go,
I hit more and more and then I'm a meathead.
I see those myths and I want to smash and that's what happens.
That's what happens.
Then your back is happy left.
Did sell me to tell me don't start slow.
Start slow.
It's warm up.
Warm Up.
You need Jesus.
You okay?
Yeah.
All that cocaine.
You doing coke?
Yeah,
but just a little bro.
Just a little,
just for,
if you do a little,
if you take the edge off,
nobody did.
And nobody ever did a bunch of cocaine and shit got better.
Well,
I wonder if people chewed bunch of coca leaves and chicken and cook.
I'm hurting by try and that,
the problem is if you crash,
you do blow and you want to start a business with your friend,
you all these fucking,
you microdose silicide been because there's no real crap.
I mean there's a weird feeling after mushroom trip,
but there's no like devastating crash that I hear people report after a cocaine,
cocaine.
Apparently when you on the come down you just wrecked.
That's one of the,
the,
the rollercoaster ride.
Like a lot of people,
they do the cocaine and then they have the crash that dopamine levels smash and
then they only feel good if they're doing cocaine again because their body is so
fucked up.
That was why you lose your house like in three years.
A buddy of mine had that in,
uh,
our other friend,
worked in a Rehab Center and was trying to explain it to us what was wrong.
Yeah,
it's no joke.
Who was sad,
sad shit.
I had somebody describe,
he emailed me and he described what we were talking about.
My friend Michael Mcdonald's best friend committed suicide and he was on the
podcast talking about it and he's got an emotional is heavy shit.
And I'm somebody I know comes to my shows,
emailed me and I guess he suffers from serious depression.
And you know,
he described the like when,
so we can always say,
well how did they,
how could they commit suicide?
They had children.
I mean,
how,
what,
what happened?
Like it makes no sense.
He said,
for me it's like being in a sauna and you know how you get too hot,
you get so hot you have to get the fuck out cause you're too out.
And he said,
only there's nowhere to go.
Ooh,
you don't have an exit.
You know,
I was in the song yesterday and I've been in the sauna lately at higher
temperatures because Gabrielle Reece,
she was on the podcast and she was seeing her husband,
you know,
Laird Hamilton,
that badass surfer.
He cranks his son up to 225 degrees.
And when,
when people like,
he's like,
who's been fucking with my son?
And I'm like,
it's like it's lower that to 25 and I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
she's telling me this.
I'm like two 25 fucks.
I put the sign up to 200 yesterday and uh,
I was thinking now while I'm lying there,
I'm like,
what if this was the world forever?
I'll use two degrees from now on forever.
The world's 200 degrees.
Like how happy would you be with your children?
Could you still laugh?
I was thinking like I could,
I can withstand that I was standing for 20 minutes.
That's what I do.
Right,
but what would I do if that was like that feeling of hot,
if it didn't kill you,
that feeling of 200 degrees out,
would you be willing to live through that?
Like how much would it sat in your life?
How much would it weigh on?
Yeah,
a lot.
Of course.
What I'm trying to say is move out of Phoenix,
Arizona books that's so massively hot.
It's not worth in God.
Get yourself a Colorado mountain home in the West in the summer.
I was just up at boulder boulder.
It needs to be a little more aggressive,
like I was just in boulder and it just like I,
I see a grown man in the middle of the day with a beard balancing a hand rail.
I'm like,
you're an able bodied man and it's Friday at fucking to go to work right now
before you know,
there's another dudes just sitting cross legged with a small little flute.
You know who you played in elementary school?
Just so on.
Aggressive male is paradise that whatever I wanted her hair that they had a sale
on his clogs it.
A few hippies bro.
Like what did I say?
Aggressive.
I would percentage of those people are there because there's 100,000 people.
It's their 10 okay.
Is there 10 people that are playing the flute?
They put cattlein talking about white,
really white,
wealthy,
white people that put caffeine and and comfortable footwear at the top of their
essentials.
Yeah,
comfortable footwear.
What's wrong with you?
I don't know,
man.
Beat to her.
Put Up fucking put on a leather sole in your fucking foot and go to work.
Have your toes,
pants to hard wooden heel.
And I want,
yeah,
I like that.
And have your toes pinch a little bit.
You saw that and where?
Some wool,
what's that called?
When you get Bunyan's get one of them things,
whatever
manufacturer shit,
drink your black coffee.
But don't you think it's nice to have a community like that where they're just
all about yoga and sought?
Not sure.
I guess it's comfortable until the Zombie apocalypse hits and then I'm not
fucking relying on that on live.
You don't want to live to the Zombie apocalypse.
Why you don't?
Boulder boulder is impossibly relaxed,
watched the walking dead,
which I don't anymore.
But when I used to watch it all the time for the just annoying me to the point
where I couldn't take anymore,
have to her while I was always like,
I don't want to do this.
Why would you want to do this to survive?
I mean people commit suicide now.
Guys that are doing well in their life is great and they have loved ones and
they commit suicide.
You tell me that people are just going to live through this nonsense.
Me Bring up the Dresden before and after the war.
Take a look at that and they say in the middle as it was his,
how's his son,
Jesus.
Speaking of 200 degrees because of the,
when the allies bombed it,
but just take a look at the,
what it looked like before and after.
Ooh,
we're so lucky we don't have to tolerate that kind of shit right now.
I remember who was the guy who wrote,
Oh God,
where the,
where the monsters are or where the,
uh,
I wrote a children's book.
It was a call where the monsters are and he was,
we was in the war and he said,
do you believe in God?
And he said,
and he just casually said,
no,
the war took care of that for me.
I never forgot it.
He just died in five years ago.
I had Eddie Izzard on yesterday and we were talking about wars of aggression.
And that most likely we've seen the end of wars of aggression.
It's trying to conquer new territory like that.
World War II was probably the last one of those.
Look at that man that's said that was dressed in dress and look like the surface
of the moon too.
They were really done with it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That lady got barbecued.
Yeah,
it's hell terrific.
Those are all bodies,
man.
She hadn't,
that was their stress and their host that,
that bill will go,
stop scrolling.
Look at that.
What the fuck,
man?
That's what war did.
That's what World War II was the structure of old Europe.
Imagine what it would look like to,
to watch those bombs hit and just level everything like that was carpet bombing
civilians that,
you know,
the,
the objective was actually to kill the Ra,
the German worker,
to really bring that country to its knees.
It was,
it was back when total devastation and the enemy was essentially a tactic.
Um,
it was a horrible,
horrible thing.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's,
is,
these images is so stunning.
Oh,
sure.
This is now human beings rebuild.
Yet they prevail.
Yeah.
And you know,
that's okay.
Um,
we were talking about yesterday was that would most likely have seen the end of
these wars of conquest where people are trying to take over new territory.
It's territory is no longer a commodity now it's services,
it's ideas,
it's technologies,
it's the land in that sense.
What do you need?
Concept was that we're moving in a better direction.
That things are becoming less and less,
at least overtly aggressive,
more people that are able to see what's really going on too and more people can
communicate.
And this is really the only generation ever like these last two or three
generations where you were able to easily translate anything that anyone saying
any other country.
Like how often do you go?
Like I'll read like could be of Madoff's,
I'm a Instagram page and it's in Russian,
you know,
and I'll translate it and so I could read what he's saying.
And I do that with a lot of his other fighters too.
I just hit the translate button.
Yeah.
I how dope is that?
Closer to that we'll do you get to know them.
You know,
you know,
and you,
you see that they,
they're pretty fucking similar.
Even though they're different,
you know,
they're into family worship and their food and their community.
They laugh,
they laugh.
Yeah.
I mean its humor,
assaults with each other.
If you live there,
you'd be in that style of living too.
And it's a hard place to live.
So you gotta be a tough mother fucker.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
But there's a predict there's,
there's something predictable too,
about how to live their certain norms and practices
with Russia being run by Putin.
That seems to me to be the last big country that might invade somebody's like
Russia being run by Putin.
You could almost see him pulling the Crimea somewhere else in the world.
You could almost see him.
I think Russia and I think the history of Russia.
I have not been there.
I was there when I was very young,
but I've not been there since I and I have people who have gotten there and
they,
they actually really enjoy it.
Then it's,
you know,
just great people like great people.
The Russian people who suffered maybe more than anybody in the 20th century,
but great people and industrious and everything else.
But I do think that they're run by a gangster.
Well,
but it's not just that they're run by a gangster.
Yes,
but I think that sometimes the way a populace thinks about certain things can
inform their destiny.
So think about this.
If you were always invaded and you had a flat topography and tanks could roll in
German tanks,
whatever it is,
and you paid such a price price for that.
Again,
I told you when I went there in 1985 you didn't see any old men.
They were all killed.
But aggression,
male aggression was what kept those Nazis it bag and when they were,
when they surrounded Leningrad.
Now Saint Petersburg and stuff like that.
A lot of stories.
And I think that when you've been traumatized to the extent that Russia has been
traumatized,
certain strengths,
you know,
the ability to stand up against aggression and to be brave and powerful,
those become that.
That becomes the commodity.
That's where,
that's the guy that gets all the money,
all the women,
all the,
you know,
whatever.
And I think that's a product of their history.
So Putin is an admired man.
Putin get,
I bet you if an had very fair elections,
he would get elected in to power.
He's respected.
You tryna see does not fair elections.
Yeah.
Well now it is a larger,
my larger point is on the record.
I'm not saying that,
I'm not saying that sir.
I don't know anything about Russian elections,
but I will say this.
I don't know why you're putting words in my mouth.
[inaudible] what the Hell's going on?
We'd get elected anyway.
I think so.
So love them.
So my allowed open criticism of them.
Well there is open criticism,
believe it or not.
Sure.
The guys who get shot no openly criticized and then they get shot.
There's actually,
there's actually,
there is a press that actually is critical.
Right,
right,
right.
But you know,
they've killed journalists.
He's not a threat to his power.
Well,
how many,
how many journalists have been murdered,
I don't know.
But enough always ends and all kinds of weird shit.
Google,
Google journalists,
critical of Putin murdered also.
His supporters will beat the shit out of you.
Yeah.
So sure.
So,
so,
so what I'm saying is that I think Russia's,
what are you saying?
I think Russia needs to embrace a diff,
the softer strengths.
Are you a foreign policy advisor?
Yes,
I am.
They said no.
This is a philosophy I have.
This is my philosophy.
Ready?
Okay.
So my philosophy has blessed this country is a great country and our culture's
an interesting culture.
Why?
Because not only are we representative hard strengths,
the military,
the NFL,
the fucking UFC,
all that shit.
The what?
Eagles and eagles' fucking ball,
right,
bro.
You're right.
That's a classic though.
Canada is fucking national.
Anthem is a beaver.
Well,
Russia has a bear.
Okay.
But so Americans,
again,
a very aggressive,
but you know what America's trade secret is?
We've also provided safe quarter two are gentler spirits.
Was this violent deaths of journalists started in the Yeltsin era.
Okay,
so they'd just been doing that forever.
Yes.
So there's just like presidents just do that in Russia.
Always was half murder,
crossfire,
terrorist act.
In 2008 there was six of those murder only.
There's another six.
Listen,
two of them were brought to trial.
Look at me right now.
Putin is Gandhi.
Putin is Gandhi compared to Khrushchev.
Gandhi compared to style and [inaudible] de Lennon,
Gannett compared to any,
anybody who was in power before him.
Those guys used to kill wholesale.
I mean,
and that's a fact up to their elbows in blood.
Who's that guy that got murdered recently that was running?
It was a political opponent.
This shot that dude down.
So when his death was not related to the journalist's work,
the conviction rate exceeds 90% what to put him in jail too if they don't just
kill him when the debt.
What does that quote though?
When the death was not related to the journalist's work to convict.
So you're talking about the rates of conviction.
That was a weird quote.
Oh,
rates of conviction are very high.
Yeah,
of course
they do.
That's all about you though.
Espionage,
those kinds of trials.
Yeah.
You're going straight to the pokey son.
Do not pass.
Go.
Good luck.
What you trial.
That's true.
The judge is like,
yeah,
listen to Ya.
20 years.
Fuck off.
But aggression,
aggressive part of the world.
United States like Russia,
however,
we're smarter.
No,
we're better.
Nope,
we might attack.
We pray our funnier.
Why are we funnier?
Because we're better.
That's the two generals are on James at the comedy store general.
This is a quiz.
Why?
Because we print,
we have protections for our people on the fringes are creatives.
Our weirdos are Fashionista is all the people that make our culture interesting.
Steven jobs,
he wasn't good at crossfit.
No.
He's going to yell at an employee.
Either was this gay guy named Martin Luther King,
but they,
but we provide at least there was Duke recourse.
At least we know that there are softer strengths.
I have to be protected.
It makes you more interesting and it makes you more creative and stronger.
You gotta be innovative.
You're innovators are Weirdos like Leonardo Da Vinci.
I apparently was gay.
What?
I sat it rages.
Wait a minute.
Guess what?
What?
There are a lot of very smart in Russia.
If you're gay,
it's not that safe for you,
right?
You get tossed off a building.
So what you do is when you do that with people who are creative and you
marginalize a group of people cause they're different in the name of purity or
whatever,
like really weird public statement about homosexuality.
The law in Russia,
like just homosexuality,
illegal in Russia,
well a lot of times they're acquainted with pedophiles.
The LGB community has real trouble there and,
and it's hard to get apartments.
It's more of subtle.
It's hard to,
it's hard to just live and make a living.
So what happens is all those creative people who could be contributing and
coming up with beautiful ideas there,
they're marginalizes perverts,
deviance.
And that's the dumbest.
Don't get to inherit the earth.
The meek.
A lot of times that the people that provide you your fucking good.
He's Russian gay propaganda law for the purpose of protecting children from
information,
advocating for a denial of traditional family values.
Oh,
the gay propaganda law and the anti gay law.
The bill.
It was unanimously approved by the State Duma on 11th of June,
2013th Holy Shit,
man.
Said he wanted to protect children from exposure to,
you know,
home activity.
Yeah,
and it was signed into law by President Vladimir Putin on the 30th of June,
2013 how long is he going to be president?
So let me,
let me ask you a better question.
So with those kinds of laws,
this kind of loss that marginalize anybody that's not,
that's not normal quote unquote,
that's not traditional prototypical male female.
Right.
Awesome.
When was the last time you bought,
and I'll wait,
what was the last time you bought one Russian product please?
Besides the fact that they're essentially a one crop economy,
which is oil and I guess some other commodities.
What happens is you kill all your creativity.
What happens is you are not a strong country.
Your weapon read isn't even good.
That's the irony of all this shit,
right?
You had that mindset and you have one idea of what strength is.
You're going to be fucking week and you're not going to be creative as a
coalition and coffee.
Good rifle.
It's a very good rifle.
Made some good shit design in 1957 I believe.
2012 previously holding the position for 2000 2008 so he's been right now he's
on seven years in office are,
sorry,
he's been longer that learn that.
Yeah,
but I mean seven now currently.
And then he did eight years before.
Yeah.
But he didn't even take four years off when he took four years off.
He was like running shit from behind.
He's got to look like I'll kill you.
Like he's like a little [inaudible].
It's a black belt in judo.
[inaudible] yeah.
Legit black belt in judo.
Like he could actually throw people around.
Probably smart as fuck.
And in his mind,
you know Putin is running a country that requires a strong man.
Yeah.
It's,
it's who they respect.
So he's caught in that too.
Even if he agreed to the world.
Let's say you're the king of the world.
How do you fix Russia?
You,
you,
you come back,
come at them with up,
you present an idea,
the idea I just presented,
which is the idea that you might want to protect the people that you consider to
be queer as deviants and Weirdos,
nerds or whatever they are.
Because those people a lot of times are your creatives.
I don't know why,
but they are.
And I think they lived in too much of a wartime culture for like for too long
identity,
develop this hardness to them that yes,
why they're lacking in the creativity and the innovation and make it a forward
that.
And I don't.
And I think that a lot of times when you've been traumatized that you're,
you're dealing still with the residue and the trauma of World War One and World
War II.
And that's very real.
And you know,
and also by the way,
communism and having nothing and,
and you know,
they have strong communities.
I mean,
my friend went to Russia and said everybody was nice to him.
Fucking they're good people and they're innovative people in their critic.
Look at how good they are at boxing.
Anything the Russians put their mind to that they,
that they hold value for like strengths,
like MMA,
like,
like boxing.
Look at how good they are.
So they're,
they're incredibly industrious discipline,
smart people.
And I just wish there,
I'm sorry,
how to get weed over.
No,
I bet you don't.
I bet if you have money,
you get everything you want.
Right?
If you got money.
Yeah.
If you're connected to the oligarchy,
but,
but I think Putin's ever tried DMT.
I think he's too measured for that.
Well,
I think you would want to know,
you know,
maybe I based on a lot of shit,
he does whatever he wants.
Yeah,
for sure.
Bizarre.
How many,
how many checks do you think he's gotten?
A stable.
Wow.
I,
I will tell you this,
I truly believe this.
I think that he does.
He can just sit there and he has women flock to him.
Oh,
for sure.
They love him for sure.
The best of them in the world.
He doesn't have to do it right.
It's not going to power.
My wife was like,
he's,
he's hot.
Whoa.
I go,
but he's,
he's a gangster.
She does.
Who doesn't like a gangster?
Ooh.
I was like,
Ooh,
Jeez.
I had to walk away.
I was like,
Whoa,
it's uncomfortable.
Steal your girl.
Yeah.
The take your Arrow still your,
your football right here with that.
Know the story,
but fucking Sturge will told me about this.
He,
uh,
who was the football player where Putin stole his ring.
Google that it's a,
the owner of the Patriots.
Was it him?
It wasn't a player,
it was just the owner of the Patriots.
Is that the guy that craft that guy?
Okay.
So he had this a Superbowl ring on it meets Putin.
Putin says,
can I hold the ring?
You know,
and then like takes the ring off,
puts it on and it's like,
hmm.
He said something like,
you could smash someone's face with this ring.
And laughed and then just walked off of the ring and they were like,
Hey,
uh,
where's the ring?
He's like,
no,
he just stole the ring.
You know,
Harvey cartel.
Really?
He just took his ring,
my ring.
No,
that's awesome.
This murdering a dick.
So he just decided he wanted it and took it off the guy's hand and this is
laughing and walked off with it.
As the story goes,
crap handed.
The diamond studded ring to Putin is a bit of show and tell I could kill someone
to string.
Putin reportedly said as he fitted to his finger,
then we craft how did his hand to get it back.
Putin surrounded by KGB agents were this least slipped the ring into his pocket.
Wow.
News circulating quickly.
The ring was not meant to as a gift,
which prompted craft to issue the statement at the time.
At the end of a very productive three hour business meeting with President
Putin,
I showed the president my most recent Superbowl ring craft set.
Upon seeing the ring President Putin,
a great knowledgeable sports fan was clearly taken by its uniqueness.
At that point,
I decided to give him the rings assembled the respect and admiration that I have
for the Russian people and the leadership of President Putin,
Aka I wanna live.
I wanna live.
Love it.
I take this,
this murdering them.
I,
I do have an admiration.
I just think you think he's ever killed anybody with a ring?
Uh,
yes.
Probably he wasn't,
but AGB guy for people to death.
George W.
Bush administration had pressured him at the time to let go of the ring to avoid
an international incident.
That's hilarious.
Wow.
In 2013 craft reneged and offered some backstory about the incident.
A legging alleging that the Bush administration had pressured him at the time to
let go of the ring.
Wow.
It would really be in the best interest of us Soviet relations if you meant to
give the ring as a present craft or crawls the White House saying,
I really didn't want to.
I had an emotional tie to the ring.
It has my name on it.
Kraft said,
I didn't want to see it on Ebay,
but met maybe putting this stuff.
I know there's a language barrier so you probably miss.
Understood,
but he's saying no,
he
didn't shut the fuck up.
They will you a Russian propaganda agent.
There was a pause at the other end of the line and the White House voice
repeated.
It would really be in the best interest.
If you meant to give the ring as a putting the faith,
bro.
No,
I'm saying that your dad,
when he took that ring,
he punked out dude and took his ring.
It's not a thief.
He's gangster.
Yeah.
Was up there pumpkin Harvey Keitel to drive 124 diamonds.
The Great Harvey Keitel.
Yes.
Told me a story.
Think it was him.
They said,
you know,
remember that I wouldn't know.
Um,
what's that?
What's that?
Fucking that La femme.
Nikita not indicated the actress and the TV show.
Yes.
I've met her once.
She was,
she went to Russia,
Candy Alexander,
so to ask.
Okay,
so she went to Russia with her boyfriend.
The Putin liked her.
He used to watch the show all the time.
I heard this from,
I bought,
I think it was Harvey Keitel.
He kept that dude out into another room and had her out on the balcony talking
to her the whole time and basically he,
the guy couldn't get back in and it was very clear that Putin was making a play
for La Femme,
Nikita.
And it's like,
you're in my town now.
You go take a seat and then you came here to take a seat.
I'm going to take what's mine and apparently she was gone.
I don't think she did anything obviously,
but you know,
let's pretend she did right there it is.
There it is,
and he dug her was what it was.
Jack Nicholson and around Bro.
Not around.
He's not there bro.
He's not allowed to be in his have legs for this.
He was apparently locked out.
He was like trying to get in the room and there was all right.
We didn't know.
It's kind of interesting when you see a guy running the country like that in
2019 that he's could run the country in that gangster fashion Morris thing that
he got people to Sean Penn.
Yeah.
It's more interesting to me that he's gotten himself in a position where people
would actually vote for,
so it technically,
it's been democratically.
I liked it.
Yeah.
I bet.
At a certain point in time they don't know who the fuck should be running things
over there.
Yeah,
probably Kalika in this end early today,
my friend,
always great.
Always come see me.
Am I made nine 10,
11.
Orlando did you,
did you,
did you talk about my dates?
Yes.
You're in the Miami Improv.
May 7th,
eighth,
and ninth,
correct?
No,
no.
Don't align.
12,
10,
and 11.
Got D nine,
10,
11.
Yeah.
Now you ruined everything.
No,
no,
no.
They,
they're listening still.
May 17,
18.
I got some days too that I just started selling.
Um,
that just went on sale.
I am going to be in where the fuck?
Dammit.
August 10th,
um,
in,
uh,
San Francisco.
I'm in mountain view,
mountain view at the shoreline amphitheater.
On August 10th,
August 9th,
I'm in Portland,
Oregon.
Woo.
Portland.
And then,
uh,
on the 23rd,
I'm in Denver,
Colorado for two shows at the Belko theater son.
Belko.
All right.
Kids that place Joe Rogan.
Dot.
Come from and keep your arms heavy in your belly tight.
What does that mean?
It just sounds like an awesome thing.
It's heavy.
I want my aunt Billy Joel Song.
Really?
Yeah.
I can't remember what the song is.
Piano man.
No.
Is an uptown girl.
Brian,
you're a silly goose and I love you.
I'll see you later.
Oh,
Brian,
town.com B r y t fat gay for tickets or [inaudible] dot com bye everybody.